on this thursday night turbulence on
deck
air canada's strategy to get through the
summer as frustration builds at airports
they delayed our flight we missed our
cruise so we are out of so much money
another shot in the arm fresh coveted
vaccine recommendations for the fall
penalties piling up brands big companies
they're they're monitoring what what
they're seeing the sponsors shutting out
hockey canada and linton bc one year
later roar through and decimated just
about everything the struggle to rebuild
a fire-ravaged village
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight eric sorensen
good evening and thanks for joining us
well just on the eve of summer holidays
there's more disappointment for
canadians ready to travel after two
years of covet restrictions and weeks of
chaos at airports the nation's largest
airline is now canceling many flights
this summer air canada says the cuts are
necessary as it grapples with soaring
demand for travel through july and
august air canada is cancelling an
average of 154 flights or 77 round trips
per day
it's going to put a lot of people behind
and frustrate a lot of people i don't
think it's going to be a good thing for
anybody this summer
especially being that everybody's just
starting to travel again now that we
thought covid was done and
air canada is unable to supply these
flights it's just
it's just outrageous
it's another blow for canada's
struggling aviation industry which had
already taken a hit when westjet
announced earlier it would be scaling
back its services this summer the
markets reacted quickly today air canada
shares dropped nearly nine percent
falling to levels not seen since the
pandemic first hit in 2020. heather
yurick's west has tonight's top story
flavia machado's efforts to get from
calgary to her home in france are going
nowhere fast we have to go to paris
today but our first flight is
three hours delay so we will miss the
second one it's a frustration travelers
have come to know well from montreal
they delayed our flight we missed our
cruise so we are out of so much money to
edmonton i've been flying last
18 years
and
i've never seen it like this with the
busy summer travel season just getting
started canada's biggest airline says it
calls for a big change
in an email to customers air canada's
president and ceo called the current
strain on global aviation unprecedented
and unforeseen with reluctance michael
rousseau writes we are now making
meaningful reductions to our schedule in
july and august they felt they had to do
it because of the pressures they were
facing as a result of federal service
failures at the airport the federal
government says it's working with
stakeholders to hire more staff at
customs and security but one passenger
rights advocate says the airline is
responsible as well they have been
selling tickets
for flies that they didn't have the
staffing didn't have a resource they
didn't have the airport capacity to
serve air canada's announcement comes
two weeks after westjet said it was
changing its flight plans as well
reducing routes in eastern canada in
order to focus more on routes here in
the west
those changes aren't expected to take
effect until early next year
westjet is reducing its summer flight
schedule compared to years past but that
was planned for and the company doesn't
anticipate canceling a significant
number of flights
frustration mounting these european
travelers aren't sure they'll be back do
you think that you'll fly canadian
airlines again
i don't know
we don't know
the baggage that comes with flying
through canadian airports just too much
to handle heather urex west global news
calgary
canada isn't the only country
experiencing travel turmoil britain made
a call to airlines today to run
realistic summer schedules and support
passengers during delays and
cancellations staff shortages at
london's heathrow airport have left
airlines struggling to keep up with
luggage and the demands of passengers
the airport asked airlines to cancel 30
flights today because passenger numbers
exceeded capacity critics accused the
airlines of selling more tickets than
they can honor which the airlines deny
word today that we're not keeping up
with our covet 19 shots as we learn to
live with kovid some canadians it seems
are becoming reluctant to get their
boosters only around 56 percent of
canadians have had at least one booster
shot yet the pandemic has not gone away
and there is still a risk that
hospitalizations will rise today
canada's health minister jeaniv duclo
said two doses are simply not enough and
that you are not up to date if you
haven't had at least a shot in the last
nine months jamie morocco has more
the one that you'll be getting today is
the madeira vaccine it's been well over
a year since covent vaccines became
available to most canadian adults but
depending on when your last shot was
health minister johnny de claus says you
may no longer be considered up to date
and to be up to date means that we've
had a dose of vaccine in the last nine
months
many have held off on more than a double
dose some citing protection from recent
infection while others are delaying
until bivalent or variant specific
vaccines becomes available
this week the us fda recommended the
next wave of coveted boosters include
components targeting omicron's ba-4 and
ba-5s of variants but canada's top
doctor wouldn't say when those will be
approved here
the current vaccine
is still very effective against
particularly serious outcomes
and deaths and so
getting that booster is something that
can be done while waiting covet shot
maker moderna is hoping the wait won't
be long thursday it became the first to
submit an application to health canada
for approval of its updated vaccine the
antibody levels versus these two new
sublineage strains show that the
antibody levels are five to six times
higher versus pre-boost both pfizer and
novovax have reported similar results at
dalhousie university dr lisa barrett has
been watching the mutations closely and
says most of us should be able to time
our next shots just ahead of a seasonal
surge now we're at a point in the
pandemic where you need to think about
the right dose of the right vaccine at
the right time in the right person one
more reminder that coven 19 in all its
forms isn't done with us yet jamie
morocco global news toronto
this should be an exciting time in
ottawa but the city is also bracing
itself for hundreds of thousands of
people to pour into the nation's capital
to celebrate canada day in person for
the first time since the pandemic began
but there are fears that demonstrations
will erupt in the downtown core just
months after convoy protesters created
gridlock for several weeks last winter
that protest was largely over vaccine
mandates that have now been relaxed or
removed but as kyle benning reports
there may be new protests this long
weekend
go down the right street in ottawa right
now and you can feel it there is a buzz
running through the capitol that this
year's canada day festivities will look
and feel different we're inviting
canadians
and ottawa citizens visitors to come and
enjoy a family-friendly activity right
we've been apart for two years now and
and this is really the time to to enjoy
each other this is the first time in
half a century where canada day events
will not be unfolding on parliament hill
also new for july first lingering
concerns from residents and community
leaders about how many so-called freedom
convoy protesters will enter the city
some individuals who organized earlier
cross-country protests have returned
one not by choice see you soon tamara
hold the line tomorrow leach was brought
back to an ottawa court for breaching
bail conditions
and conservative leadership hopeful
pierre poliev showed his support
thursday joining james tom the canadian
soldier who was court-martialed for
criticizing vaccine mandates bridget
belton protested earlier this year but
won't be in ottawa this week she has
sympathy for those who are still
rallying against pandemic mandates the
lack of freedom
it's still not returned a lot of people
assume that we have all our freedoms
back ottawa's mayor and police chief
have said officers will be ready for
anything more than 800 rcmp officers who
were deputized for the springs rolling
thunder convoy are available and on
standby some organizers say
demonstrations could take place every
weekend up until labor day so this could
just be the start of several loud months
on the hill
eric
kyle benning in ottawa thank you
to ukraine now where western allies are
declaring a major victory in the ongoing
war with russia after moscow announced
the total withdrawal of troops from the
strategic black sea outpost of snake
island
if you wanted evidence of the amazing
ability of the ukrainians to fight back
to overcome adversity and to repel the
russians and look at what has happened
uh just today on snake island where
again
russia has had to seed ground
located just 35 kilometers off ukraine's
coast the strategic outpost has been
occupied by russian forces since late
february effectively blockading
ukraine's odessa region and preventing
grain exports from leaving nearby ports
russia calls its withdrawal a gesture of
goodwill to prove it was not obstructing
shipments but in new video released
today ukraine's defense ministry claims
to have driven the russian forces out
overnight with the help of weapons
provided by its international partners
the battle for ukraine's donbass region
is still raging the city of lisychansk
is under constant shelling and the
russian military tries to grind down
ukrainian forces but canada is now
promising more help this summer with
plans to send armored vehicles and
drones david aiken reports
canada will answer the call from the
ukraine for vehicles that can safely
move ukrainian troops through combat
zones as the nato summit finished in
madrid prime minister justin trudeau
said canada will send 39 armored
personnel carriers overseas this summer
all of us have recommitted to being
there to support ukraine
because they are fighting not just for
their own territory but our democracies
the carriers are built in london ontario
and were to be part of a delivery of 360
armored carriers ordered up by canada's
military but canada can wait for that
delivery a little bit longer the need in
ukraine is more urgent the best use for
canadian security and for geopolitical
stability is to put them in the hands of
ukrainians but we are
committed to replenishing those stocks
canada will also provide ukraine with
six more drone cameras i think it's
terrific that we are taking our
responsibility very seriously in terms
of contributing and doing our share for
collective defense
and uh with the russian invasion of
ukraine we just realized how vulnerable
we are but canada has now exhausted the
500 million dollars the trudeau
government set aside in the 2022 budget
for military aid to ukraine trudeau said
ukraine can't expect canada to continue
to do more but by many metrics canada's
defense capability is shrinking
retention and recruitment is short of
targets the department is looking to cut
costs and data published by nato itself
shows canada's defense spending is
falling canada should really allocate
more in terms of our financial
commitment to nato we're not meeting the
two percent threshold the defense
minister sees things differently we are
the sixth largest defense budget in nato
countries and we will continue
to be
wholly committed to this multilateral
alliance in many ways but when you
measure the country's defense spending
relative to the size of its economy well
canada ranks 24th among 29 nato allies
in fact that ratio defense spending
relative to gdp is going to be just 1.27
percent this year that's nato's figure
and that's the lowest for canada since
2016. eric
david aiken in madrid thank you david
it's being called a crisis of legitimacy
coming up the intensifying criticism
against the u.s supreme court
history was made in washington today as
katanji brown jackson became the first
black woman to be sworn in as a justice
of the u.s supreme court but it comes at
a time when the court faces questions
over its legitimacy after rulings that
rolled back the rights of americans and
challenged the rule of the federal
government jackson proskow has that
story so help me god her appointment
changes the course of history
but it's unlikely justice katanji brown
jackson will be able to stop the
historic rollback of american rights at
the hands of the supreme court we now
have a political supreme court in the
united states of america and i and i
think a lot of us lawyers
in particular
never thought we would utter those words
in the past month the conservative
majority on the bench has tossed aside
five decades of abortion access told
states they can't regulate who carries
guns in public and thursday in a blow to
the fight against climate change the
court stripped the powers of the federal
government to regulate greenhouse gas
emissions
and you think this decision by the court
was an outrage or a significant mistake
vote
show up and vote
that's how we'll change it the rulings
are at odds with elected governments and
popular opinion leading to a crisis of
legitimacy for the highest court in the
u.s
if people were paying attention
this was the logical result of seated
work that took decades to ultimately
come to fruition conservative groups and
republican politicians have spent years
working to appoint justices friendly to
their cause
the court itself has no ethics code and
there are no consequences for justices
who may have lied under oath about their
view of cases they ultimately ruled on
like abortion
roe v wade
is an important precedent of the supreme
court it has been reaffirmed many times
the result is a body that is unelected
and unaccountable and is drastically
reshaping american life with remarkable
speed
in its next term the court will take up
a case that could radically reshape
elections for president and congress by
letting states decide exactly how
elections are run
that is the basis of the same legal
theory that former president donald
trump was pushing as he sought to
overturn the 2020 election
jackson prosko global news washington
ahead why some canadian companies are
skating off the ice and taking their
sponsorships with them
you're watching global national
[Music]
it's been a week and a half since hockey
canada executives were called to
parliament hill after disturbing
allegations against several players
hockey canada responded but many mps
were not satisfied with what they heard
and now some large corporate sponsors
are pulling their money off the ice mike
drollet reports
the hits are piling up for hockey canada
tim hortons has now suspended its
funding to the national organization
joining scotiabank telus and canadian
tire in urgently seeking concrete
details from hockey canada about how it
intends to change the culture of the
sport hockey canada released a statement
saying more needs to be done and more
quickly a similar message to the one
that irked mps at a special hearing last
week in ottawa and leading to the
government freezing federal funding i
haven't got really from any of you
reassurances that hockey canada has
changed in their harassment bullying and
abuse policies hockey canada has been
under fire since it was accused of
trying to keep quiet a multi-million
dollar settlement to a woman who claimed
eight players including members of the
national junior team had assaulted her
at a 2018 gala in london ontario none of
the allegations have been proven in
court and hockey canada says it did all
it could since the accused refused to
cooperate with their investigation but
marketers say there's a big difference
between legal and moral responsibility
and bob stellick sees public opinion so
squarely against hockey canada right now
sponsors have no choice but to step away
everything comes in an avalanche and it
comes so quickly
you can't you can't really control your
message because it's coming at you from
everyone everywhere everyone's a pundit
everyone has an opinion so
brands big companies they're they're
monitoring what what they're seeing and
they're demanding action similar to what
was promised after the graham james
scandal that transformed sheldon kennedy
from a victim to an activist this is not
about wrecking sport this is about
getting this right yet he says the
culture has barely changed at the
national level hockey canada he says
needs to get its priorities straight if
we spent as much time on this stuff as
we do on the power play or even half the
amount of time on on these issues as we
do on the power play
we're going to get better teams we're
going to get better individuals can
hockey canada come up with a plan of
action its financial future depends on
it microlight global news toronto
litton revisited the bc town wiped out
by fire we return one year later
tornado and not just one environment
canada confirms three tornadoes touched
down in parts of saskatchewan on
wednesday night as storms moved through
the province the severe weather is still
being investigated but all three
tornadoes were given tentatively the
lowest intensity ratings damage from
affected areas included downed trees and
power lines and destroyed farm
structures there's no word of any
injuries
it was a different type of natural
disaster that happened at this time last
year in british columbia the entire
community of litton bc was destroyed the
small bc town was virtually wiped out by
a massive inferno one year ago right
after setting the record for the hottest
temperatures recorded in canadian
history two people were killed while
hundreds lost their homes a tragedy also
seen as a sign of the future as our
climate warms
nitu garcia is in linton tonight with
more on this summer anniversary meetup
eric it is overcast with temperatures in
the low 20s but a day before the fire
tore through it was 49.6 degrees here
the hottest ever recorded in canada and
as you can tell by the destruction still
here a year later the weather is the
only thing that's dramatically different
one year ago star drynock a mother of
two was out of town getting groceries
when she got a call linton was burning i
felt helpless being away from them
my youngest for almost a week or two
because i couldn't get to her
at the time she thought her father was
missing too
terrifying because i know he wouldn't he
wouldn't leave he's since been hailed a
hero for staying back to try and save
properties proud to say that you know
he's my dad after spending six months in
a hotel and being displaced again by
november's floods in bc she now lives in
an apartment in the city of merit about
two hours away from litton this was a
gym
that was a really popular cafe
some residents marking the year since
they lost those community favorites are
burying a time capsule as crews work to
remove metal and contaminated ash
the federal government recently
announced 77 million in new funding for
net zero fire resistant rebuilds roared
through and decimated just about
everything among the three first nation
reserves that lost homes is linton first
nation where some residents have started
to return home 39 units on the ground
today
that are being in preparation for the
people to
lost the homes on the reserve to be able
to move to
[Music]
a train was widely speculated to have
caused the fire but the transportation
safety board of canada reported in
october it had no evidence to support
that the rcmp and bc wildfire service
are still investigating like a
sightseeing for dry knock the experience
inspired her to renew training as a
medic to work on the front lines of
future fires i know
what bc went through last year and i
know there's a shortage of medics out
there so to me it's a new start new
foundation
as they all try to build back stronger
nitu garcia global news linton
bc rebuilding good for them and that's
global national for this thursday night
i'm eric sorensen tonight's york canada
is this lupine flower field in bonshaw
prince edward island we love seeing your
canada so please email your pictures to
viewers at globalnational.com
colleen christie will be here tomorrow
thanks for watching
[Music]
you